hi I'm Ryan right and i'm gerry welcome
two reasons to see will we give you
reasons to see and not to see the host
so let's hang out see possible after an
alien race has taken over mankind by
taking over their bodies and erasing
their memories our main character
Melanie is taken over by an alien named
wanderer but Melanie still lives inside
the mind of her body sounds confusing
keep up people Melanie will risk
everything to protect the people she
cares most about proving that love can
conquer all in a dangerous new world
reason to see number one Wanda or the
wanderer so basically Saoirse Ronan
placed two characters in a sense because
the one character is Melanie who's the
human character was part of this
resistance like hell
who then gets captured and they put this
alien soul there called into her body
and that's wanderer so so wander takes
over her body and then Melanie is still
there in her head human bodies take a
lot of getting used to they're not like
the others we have inhabited their
emotions are powerful if her will has
survived along with a memory she may
resist from within yeah then when
wanderer comes across the human
resistance they nicknamed her Wanda one
of the characters that she plays is
really portrayed very well actually
there's performance on wanderer it was
really good she's this person who's kind
of exploring humanity they is starting
to feel emotion she's never felt before
because that's always what makes
humanity great and movies like this is
our emotions our ability to choose
despite how terribly we are with the
environment and everything else it's our
emotions that really save us I gotta
know it's melon Hitler
oh yeah that's always it's always the
kind of a role I feels it's gotta be
kind of tough to play because you have
to act as though everything is foreign
to you and you don't quite understand
being human and you've been human all
your life she grounds his movie I mean
she she keeps it compelling even when it
veers off and did into cheese yeah it's
a role it's a role of a lot of depth and
there's layers to it yeah so she does a
really good job especially the
interaction back and forth between Wanda
and Melanie's voice inside of her head
please gonna see number two William Hurt
William Hurt plays uh Melanie's uncle
the leader of the human resistance gym
he really elevates this movie's material
already i'm really happy they cast him
in this role he's wise and Wiley at the
same time you're always glad to see him
on screen found this place by accident
almost died trying to find a way out of
these cave and he does have those
leadership qualities that are necessary
because out of all the rebels he's the
leader them and he's the only one who
has shows compassion towards the alien
reason to see number three the concept I
don't know how much you know about this
new
almost every human has been successfully
occupied
this is actually such a cool concept to
me it's like what happens after invasion
of the Body Snatchers in a way it's a
really cool world to explore I love all
the elements they have going for it you
know they have this idea of the alien
race and then the human resistance and
then they also got some great human
complexity going on there's some awesome
science fiction in here there's so
there's a lot of great things to really
explore and just the whole universe is
laid out very well yeah well see the
thing is I feel like this movie is kind
of a punching bag just because the name
Stephanie Meyer is on it and say what
you will you have [ __ ] all over Twilight
if you want but the core concept of this
movie is actually really cool do not
change this world but experiences even
if it doesn't always work there's a lot
of cool ideas and this whole thing of
two people trapped in the same body
trying to figure out life in the world
around them is actually really
compelling at least on a molecularly
it's the most literal interpretation of
internal struggle reason to see number
four sometimes it's so bad it's good
especially in Act one people yeah there
are some moments in there where you're
like wow oh my god this is not a good
movie yeah it wasn't like Twilight where
all the movies I've seen a toilet after
a while I'm just like this is so
irritating like at least when it's
wanted when the silly moments come up at
least you get a kind of a laugh out of
it you're like what are you doing yeah
that's the thing is like there are some
moments that are just absolutely just
horrendous but you can't disregard their
entertaining moments reason to see
number five has its moments surprisingly
around the time of Act two and for the
rest of the movie there's a lot of
surprisingly very well fleshed out
scenes that I actually really enjoyed
there's some really good drama that
pulled me into the movie you know I
don't want to give away the ending but
the ending is
was a little bit emotional to me ya know
I turn up man I'm not gonna let it go on
the record and say I cried during this
if the movie goes back and forth between
being like wow this is really bad I
think oh that is a surprisingly really
good scene this is one of the weirdest
mixed bags I've ever seen began there
are some stuff that legitimately is
really cool and really like emotional or
it strikes a tone that's just really in
girls yeah there's something like really
intriguing plot points to like there's a
legitimately great sci-fi romance buried
in this movie it just needed like one or
two rewrites and it would have been an
exceptional felt exactly reason to see
number six cinematography I think the
one thing that even if you're a hater
you cannot deny their the film looks
good throughout you know this looks
incredible yeah there's all the time if
I remember even in Act one going you
know what despite the fact of how kind
of cheesiness is it still looks really
good well in the cinematography has a
big hand in settling this movie yeah and
then in the direction of the the
cinematography because it's like it
really I mean first off to just capture
the gorgeous landscapes really well like
you know they're the frames are all
really interesting and it all
contributes to this weird future yeah
because it works it works well in
comparison with you know the science
fiction world that you see especially in
act 1 and then with watching kind of the
nature does desert kind of world and you
know hack to throughout so when you get
to see both collide and eat without the
cinematography working so well together
it probably would have seemed very weird
alright so let's move on to the reasons
not to see the host reason not to see
number one Melanie's voice like we
mentioned earlier melanie is still alive
inside of her body but like in the mind
of Melanie and she can be pretty
annoying sometimes yeah
it's it's with the way they wrote it's
like a 13 year old girl all the sudden
it's like two writers wrote melody yeah
and wonder because there's part way some
of the time you're like no yeah I get it
Melanie I get what you're doing and then
other times you're like dude shut up the
dialogue does not match the characters
age it is hard to adjust to especially
in Act one please about to see number
two the romance stopped dreaming about
okay I'll be honest with you there's
romance in here with a character named
Jared played by Jeremy Irons son max
irons excess and anyway um there is some
horrible romance in those moments
especially oh gosh there's a scene in
Act one when they're on the couch
outside and they're talking to each
other and I just remember everyone in
the theater cracking up at a scene where
they're clearly trying to be as serious
as possible but oh man it just does not
work and then there's moments where he's
talking to wanderer that are just um no
and the fact of the matter is you kind
of forget about the romantic aspect to
it with them and it's just never felt
that doesn't you're never really rooting
for them to get back together or for it
to work out it's just that's the biggest
issue I have with the romance in it I
don't think the romance is all bad
because I think the concept again is
really cool of you guys there's two
people stuck in a body and then you have
two other guys one of whom loves actual
Melanie and one of whom loves wanderer
and I think that's actually a cool thing
to play with yeah there's a character in
the movie I named Ian who is in love
with the actual wander at first he tries
to murder her by choking her to death
but eventually without ready hurdle
explanation wanna hear he ends up
falling in love with her for some reason
but it's it's still kind of weird at
first but eventually when you get move
past it becomes better than the story
with Jared yeah I actually like a lot of
their romantic scenes together and again
I just I just think it's against its its
suffers because of the right
reason not to see number three awkward
moments sometimes it's so bad it's good
sometimes it's so bad that it's so bad
that is awkward to actually watch some
scenes I was like doing this because I
didn't want to look at the screen as I
felt so uncomfortable to actually watch
some of these moments my name is Jared
home I haven't spoken to her Nelly
Schumann day in two years Melanie
Stryder
this is the beginning of a love story
and that might not seem like a big deal
except for one thing this is the future
and humanity is all but extinct there's
a scene where Wonder is thinking about
it faking he just get uncomfortable
again where we're wanderer and Melanie
are we kind of taking turns on baking
apple with their boys and it's such a
weird [ __ ] you can seen that I actually
looked into my friend and went oh my god
what the [ __ ] is going on right now
reason not to see number 4 bad dialogue
that is probably the first thing you'll
notice but this movie is just how bad
the dialogue actually is it's cracking
me up looking back on some of the lives
I don't want to give any of them away
for you just watch it there's some awful
awful dialogue in certain scenes well a
lot of scenes that's probably the most
constructively acting yeah anything is
like that is the dialogue after a while
you just kind of got to get used to it
and sometimes it's so expositional that
it's like the script is like treating
the audience like they're idiots you
know it's it can be pretty bad at times
it's not human till we stop actin human
I miss everything about her okay so with
all that aside I guess I should probably
tell you what my recommendation on it is
Ryan's consensus they're cheesy but
sometimes good reasons to see the host
there are cheesy but sometimes good
reasons to see the host yeah despite the
fact that you know essentially from a
filmmaker point of view it's not the
greatest movie but regardless I was
entertained throughout Jerry's consensus
honest say that there are some
surprisingly good reasons to see the
hose there are some surprisingly good
reasons to see the host so this film is
like the ultimate mixed bag for me cuz
you know if some of it is pretty bad and
then there's other stuff that's
legitimately really cool but ultimately
you know it's not twilight it's it's own
beast and at the end of the experience I
walked out digging the [ __ ] out of it
alright guys thanks for checking out the
video go ahead and click down to the
bottom in the comment box tell us your
reasons to see or not to see the host
and if you like check out my straight to
the point review of the host and if you
want to know the differences between
this review in that review just hear the
title it's straight to the point click
the link right here and if you want to
see more episodes of reasons to see
click the link right y'all last one I'll
least if you want to get updated every
time a new video is out subscribe
subscribe people subscribe to our
Channel please subscribe we are the
hosts of reasons to see ah ah sound like
George is why uh yeah or the count now
yeah I hi George McFly is apparently the
cabbie yeah
not the same thing you know they're both
strange
you